With this being the world's smallest radio,...
...it had to have a sales pitch to match.
And here it was.
A radio that could fit in your pocket.
There's only one problem though.
It didn't fit in the average-sized pocket.
The solution was a little bit sneaky.
Sony made people from their sales team wear bigger pockets...
...that were custom-made to fit the radios...
...but at least they could fit now.
From then on, orders for the new device came flooding in.
The Americans loved the Sony TR-63.
And it was widely popular with teenagers.
Some music historians state that the 1957 Sony TR-63...
...was instrumental in the rise of rock and roll music...
...because it allowed kids to independently listen to their music...
...finally freed from the tyranny of their parents.